Artie has such loyal fans I can't tweet
about the show without 10,000 people
10,000 feeling where's Adi
Marathi like he'll be in the trailer and
they'll be like Marathi I'm going to
trailer yeah it needs to be more Adi are
you guys worried about him because
everybody was tweeting like apparently
like all these gay get help and recently
like are you guys concerned when you
said that I was like did something
happen laughs no no no the world of
friends have already is unfortunate but
yeah we're concerned about Artie for
sure his nose looks awful yeah and he's
in pain and he's suffering he's you know
he's trying to get sober but fighting
the good fight and it's really hard and
for people who spend a lot of time with
him yeah you get an up-close look at the
horrors of addiction I got a very
specific RT though so I'm not like maybe
the best party like Quinn or some of
these people that have known already for
like a really long time maybe you have
you known already a long time well yeah
so I bet you would you know you have
more of a sense of the flavor the RT
that I know and I'm not just saying this
to help his career was very very
professional I used to joke I was like
where's the I thought you'd be throwing
up dry cigarettes by now but he'd come
in and know his lines nobody's funnier
yeah kills scenes I've said many times I
think a big reason wouldn't you agree
our pilot got picked up was because of
his performance oh yeah in the pilot
which he improvised and at the end
everyone applauded like Nick Nolte it
really what I've never seen we've done
three seasons now no matter what I do no
applause Artie Artie got the crew to
apply what so he's an interesting cuz he
does when he's functioning he's great
like yeah show up he would do Howard and
I was doing ona and I would be getting
here exactly the same time as him and
I'm like he does heroin and I'm not
showing up five minutes we got here at
the same time no I know we playing with
a pretty big hand yeah
and he's still winning was is it was his
nose like going through the process as
you were shooting well you gotta have a
nose update his nose was different right
but it would be different every day I'm
not trying to be funny it was a
different note but that's a mask when
you're trying to do a show and you're
like I'm not necessarily shooting the
scenes in order but your nose keep from
being Bhasin there was nose continuity
issues again not trying to be funny it's
just a fact and and my heart breaks for
already it's something that you'd
sometimes have to
you know fix or talk about or you know
we'll work around or work it around you
from behind over-the-shoulder
do you talk about it on the show or do
you just try to deal with it behind the
scenes we didn't talk about the nose on
the show yeah and you know we tried to
talk about what he's going through on
the show so last season we did a whole
episode and it was basically about Pete
realizing how bad Artie's addiction is
and the fact that no matter how much he
tries to help it doesn't work and it's
really up to Artie to and I find the
strength to do it and art eroded you
know you know you improvise and talked
about it and was very brave about
showing how painful his world can be and
it was a really important episode
because you know Artie was showing
people like yeah this is awful yeah and
and if I tell you the truth about it
maybe there's someone out there when
they're in that moment where they might
try something to do something they might
go I don't I don't want to experience
what the art he's going through he
wishes he could put it down more than
anything yeah he always says is the
worst moment of his life was the first
time that he tried heroin than it was
that he because of why that would lead
to he wishes he could take it back and
he says the second he did it in his mind
he went I'm in big trouble because that
game ended I think everyone feels that
way about heroin now most people I'm
guessing who get hooked on it don't do
heroin ago this sucks like it's probably
amazing there is a way to get off at
though I mean if he wanted to there is a
way it's very difficult but there is a
way to stop it you also I mean it is a
disease that addictive personality mixed
with the heroin I think is what we're
dealing with
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app
[Music]